very kind introduction it's right um I
did switch uh three years into a
six-year PhD so if anyone ever wants to
make a enormous leap I have in the past
served as a resource and I'm happy to
again
um um so
but today uh at least for the formal
part of our interaction I'm here to talk
about systems for uh helping people form
ideas about what they want to do and a
better understanding of the world and
what how they want to act on it and how
they communicate that to others
especially if that other is a computer
rather than another human being
uh so um I also want to just acknowledge
the generous funding of uh of course uh
Harvard and the Harvard Radcliffe
Institute which supported me over uh the
last year and uh of course the NSF for
which much of this work would not have
happened
so let's
um I I think it's so beautiful that
Michael mentioned that I started in HCI
thinking about large classrooms because
I actually in reflecting on what I
wanted to share with you today I came
all the way back to that kind of origin
story of
um why was I doing human computer
interaction I was a teaching fellow in a
massive undergraduate computer
architecture class where people were
producing pages and pages of esoteric
code that was only in that class the
professor had invented the language that
was unreadable 30 years ago we were
still using it and so I as a TF would go
from student to student and just be like
there's not the right division of labor
here I can't look at these pages of code
and know what's going on the computer
could could look at it right if only the
computer could help me have a better
awareness of all the different design
choices that are being populated by all
these students such that I could have
the kind of conversations that only I as
a TF as a human
um can have with them so you know for
example we found that um uh students
were constructing Turing machines
um most TFS had taken the class before
they had made their turing machine and
that was the way you made it made it to
you know satisfy the assignment and so
when they met a student who was making
the turing machine some other way they'd
say
what are you doing that's wrong start
over right when in reality there were
multiple Turing machines that were that
met the spec and um by analyzing the
space of solutions we were able to tell
the TF we were able to better inform how
they would act in the world
um and so this this
uh notion of kind of helping people act
better in the world and understand what
they want to do what conversations they
want to have
um it comes up again when I'm talking
with my collaborators uh in the medical
world right
um I have a collaborator who's in uh
chronic pain management and he says you
know yes there's one of you know 20
different drugs I could prescribe but a
huge part of it is the relationship with
the patient and me helping them
understand that given their
sensitivities to various you know prior
drugs side effects that you know we're
we're having a conversation there he's
almost selling in a good way uh helping
them consolidate a plan to address uh
their pain with the chosen medication
um and computers can help that doctor
maybe think about the back you know
instead of doing mental back of the
envelope calculations of like quick
pattern matching oh yeah this drug
worked for this similar person last time
we can help them so this is the kind of
problem that I find really exciting um
one last connection here is you know
when we're thinking about communicating
to the computer or thinking about what
kind of
um how the computer is playing this role
like I like this particular stock photo
um because it reminds me that sometimes
in our user studies we found uh that
like say we're trying to
we're asking the user to
give examples of what they want and the
computer will try to guess
something you know program that fulfills
what the user in this study wants and
sometimes in that interaction the user
will be like oh I got it I know the
regular expression that I want I can
write it down for you right now
but in our interface because we were so
focused on how supporting them to get
the computer to guess it that we've
never had an interface affordance to
allow them to write in the answer
you know like you know if we were so
focused on the communication of the
computer as opposed to no what really
matters is the person walks away with
the thing they need
so um I generally think of this as kind
of AI assisted task formulation
um and or
uh AI assisted task completion so each
of my projects sometimes it's just
helping the user have a better
understanding of what they want to do uh
sometimes it's helping they have a
notion what they want to do and the AI
is helping them achieve it sometimes
it's uh both and so I actually think
about this
now more than ever as a conversation
so you know you can go back to on
Language by Herbert Clark from a book by
a psychologist I think Emeritus now here
at Stanford um a classic on all the
minute steps that make conversation
between humans work
um and so I've been you know asking
myself
well if you remove the human and
introduce
some silicon right what parts of those
little things change what little
interface affordances are possible or
what are additional cognitive uh tasks
that if we're not aware of them we may
design an interface that is subpar
so
I I am not going oh sorry uh yeah and by
the way just as a caveat I know there's
some approaches out there in computer
science which try to model the context
the opinions the values the goals all
that I am just assuming in all my work
that that is inaccessible and is a
Fool's errand to try to guess so it just
um not to say that it's not valuable
work but that's
um not generally what I'm trying to do
so human AI communication
um I am currently kind of accumulating
from all these papers over the years
I'm trying to think about all these
little pieces all the little details
um so I'm going to step you through the
details that I've identified so far from
these papers
um I I uh they they require kind of uh
controlled user studies to fully you
know you know falsifiable hypotheses to
test to tell you that these are exactly
right but I'm going to tell you about
them in case they spur your thought
about what you might look into and then
I'm going to go into detail into our two
most recent papers one that was
conditionally accepted on Friday
and I'll talk about for the first time
so bear with me okay so first thing um
that I've noticed is uh it really just
go real fast
um when you're expressing your intent
sometimes you realize as you are
expressing it that the intent's not
quite what you thought it was right so
um there's intent refinement
opportunities at the expression point
um if you allow people to
uh provide multiple expressions of their
like you know oh I think this constraint
is something I care about but in
parallel
also say actually there's this other
constraint maybe that's the one that I
care about
suddenly if they are not forced to
um you know kind of commit to something
it's much less anxiety provoking to say
you know computer try this or because
you know it's so removing the anxiety or
the consequences of giving a
specification that ends up not being
what you want parallel program synthesis
in this in the swage program um you know
this was this was a huge win to our
users
um supporting multiple modalities if
possible um like annotating concrete
examples or allowing them um not just
kind of saying words or
that kind of thing um
extracting and displaying A diversity of
examples from data if the data is
available or generating a diversity of
examples so again from psychology
literature common ground right those
examples can be that kind of ground and
Common Ground that reflect what you want
and are also observable to the computer
unlike the values that you hold in your
mind over uh you know your personal
values
um also like uh showing inferred
commands if possible just the simple
difference between talking to your
Google home Mini
versus uh Siri on your phone where you
can see the the transcription of what it
thinks you said
um make a huge difference uh the system
State the same way that uh you ask your
Google home mini in your kitchen to
cancel the timer and it does but you
didn't realize it had two timers and it
canceled the wrong one because it was
confidently wrong because requesting
clarifications if the system is
uncertain is not foolproof because it
could you know
um
all of these uh issues again these are
just observations that I've accumulated
over working on these projects that I'm
sharing with you right now
um the integration step I think that we
often
there's been a lot of work including
some of my own on
creating writing assistance like hey
chat DBT or you know a large language
model can continue my sentence and maybe
that'll serve as inspiration for where I
want to go many of you are probably
making use of predictive text in your
Gmail
um there is uh non-trivial integration
costs that we can think about
um uh that have come up especially when
you're doing kind of more creative tasks
as opposed to dashing off an email
um
or we could you know um
there's a lot of cost in looking over
the results of execution so this is
really just the good old Gulf of
evaluation right um Flash Fill the one
of the first program synthesis tools
that was commercially available uh you
could go into Excel and give a couple
examples and it will synthesize a Excel
formula that it thinks is what you want
right and yet it gives you basically no
support for
um looking over thousands and thousands
of rows of data right you you
um so there's all these kind of inner
tasks that are maybe subtle if uh but
that if we don't support them we are are
batting below our possible batting
average in terms of supporting the
quickness and accuracy and fewest number
of round trips to commute to get to what
we want and have the computer correctly
understand it um finally
um with each one of these interactions
um person is going to be updating their
mental model of the machine hopefully
correctly and updating their mental
model of the world and any relevant data
so I think um you know I I put this out
here as a a living document as I
accumulate and do systems um I think
each one of these
uh you know if you can take them and go
to a new uh domain and say you know what
are the implications of this of
supporting this cognitive task in this
new domain
um and and so I you know and if you do
that please tell me about it
um so
um I am going to talk about
uh this Loop in the context of uh our
most recent paper patat which is
um
the pattern-based Thematic annotation
Tool uh this work is in collaboration
with Toby Lee's lab and led by simran
but also with the help of Zhang xiaohang
and Yi hao
um and so this is uh conditionally
accepted under the title Hewitt AI
collaborative qualitative coding with
explainable interactive rule synthesis
um
so the back story
um because you know
you can all read the paper eventually
um but you can't necessarily get access
to kind of like the backstory behind the
paper the small backstory behind this is
that um I mentioned uh flashfill when I
was a postdoc at Berkeley and hired on a
program synthesis Grant I had to do I
was required to do one program synthesis
project as an ACI person I said I don't
know what that is but I will do it I
highly recommend uh putting yourself out
there like that if you have the
opportunity because it was the hammer I
didn't know I needed basically you know
this they Microsoft had just come out
with this toolkit called Pros where I
was like hey we have a set of grammars
over say patterns and strings right or
or
um you could give us a grammar and we
will if you give us examples we'll
synthesize a program to you in that
grammar
that meets your spec and you know given
our uh given your ranking function is
hopefully what you want
um and of course the devil's in the
details in terms of Designing that
ranking function or designing an
interface that supports you recognizing
the program you want given an imperfect
ranking function
um so I've always wanted
um to
have uh interactive program synthesis
programs be synthesized over text but
not just the raw text patterns in raw
text but patterns over
um parts of speech
that seemed like a much more powerful
grammar that they did not have and so we
did it this is sorry it was like uh that
that's that's the high level I'm
extraordinary excited that that um and
and the the application that we decided
to apply this to to show its utility is
thematic analysis so thematic analysis
in terms of a a rich human AI
communication problem
um is one where it's iterative where the
user requires it requires deep
engagement on the part of the user
um and there are many different valid
outcomes because the
um I mean obviously we talk about
iterative reliability but if anyone's
familiar with that paper about like
iterator reliability being not always
the most important thing it could even
move you away from interesting
observations that are less frequent
right because you're just focusing on
consistency it's like if you're trying
to be consistent you're actually
steering away from the interesting and
big ambiguous stuff that you might that
might be a good part of your research so
there's there's multiple out valid
outcomes and the success ultimately is
is defined by the the user's research
questions right two different people
could have the same data but have
different research questions and have
entirely different code books so it's a
really um I think it's a good problem to
look at
we did a formative contextual inquiry
study with five experienced qualitative
coders who did coding of their own data
and then an interview afterwards
they often did have this hypothesis
driven approach right so it kind of
validated that they that the research
question is determining a great deal of
what their path through the data is but
that the code book does evolve how many
folks have done called it for coding
themselves
so at least half of you
um so for that half this is redundant
for the half that hasn't done it uh
that's for you um so uh the themes of
interest to a given participant um
evolved significantly
um for every step you know that you're
defining new themes
um even though they may be started with
an initial formation of their intents
right your your by definition this is a
situation where that initial intent is
is going to be wrong right we have to
have those round trips
um participants quoted it expected the
AI
um to improve and expand their
capabilities as long as they had control
and Leadership
and they tried to understand the
rationale behind the coding suggestions
because that was part of what kind of
made them decide whether or not to trust
it
um and also what they could learn from
it because ultimately right
um the ground truth is in quotes right
uh you know the
um
it's a lot of this a lot of the prior
work on adding AI assistance has been
optimized for accuracy not on user
takeaways but the ultimate goal of
qualitative coding is not to build a
model of the data
or even to produce the annotated data
set right the goal is to discover the
themes that you walk away from
that answer that should light on your
research questions
again going back to like you are a
better actor in the world because of
this assistance as opposed to getting
the computer to do the thing
so the first kind of my my the primary
design goal here is to optimize our
interface for and our system design for
the users learning
um about the patterns of data so you
know you could think about this as kind
of a
two-dimensional uh uh space I mean
obviously I I completely made up curve
um and maybe there will be a new
technology that just totally you know is
way off the curve but for now right like
generally these lower transparency
methods like deep neural networks
they're harder to optimize for users
learning because they are somewhat uh
Black Box whereas if we give up a little
bit of accuracy
we can gain a great deal in transparency
and that is a worthwhile trade in our
argument if the outcome is not how good
your model is at taking additional
interview data but rather for you to
understand you know
the answer to your research question so
um support transparency it's easier for
the user to understand and validate or
modify the model directly right or
indirectly through correcting
explanations of the model's decision on
an individual piece of data
so um pattern rules are really promising
in this area so you know this Cody not
our work from uh to kaizago uh had
um a uh a code rule engine where it
would take your examples and come up
with an example of a rule you can see
um like they're doing kind of some
stemming and some logical over but it's
a very basic language and then there
because that's too basic a language
they're it's it's not I'm guessing it
was not powerful enough in terms of
accuracy to be useful that they augment
it with kind of a a black box machine
learning engine so now you're getting
um both kind of these um
recommendations based on the pattern and
also recommendations separately from
this opaque black box and so there's
they're they're kind of trying to have
their cake and eat it too
um it's it's terrific work
um we went a step further
and um we have we are synthesizing rules
from examples uh like them but maybe
slightly different machinery
but um we're using a regular expression
grammar over parts of speech entities
literals like you know just a particular
word stems of uh words wild cards and
semantic soft matches where something is
price this is where you could
technically call it neurosymbolic
which is all the rage today
um uh where you know say uh synonyms as
identified by a large language model
um but but not kind of an opaque way
right not just kind of like oh we we
have an interface where you can look at
what were the what were matched under
the notion of synonym
by the way if anyone has a question
I am very open to being interrupted I
just just so you know
um and I'd also just want to point out
that like um you know traditional
humidity Loop or interactive machine
learning approaches they are often I
mean they're not really built for
iteration they're built for like I know
what a dog is it's very unambiguous you
asked me to create a classifier for dog
you give me labels I predict the rest of
the dogs
um and that's not the process here so
you can see you know part of the
interface here it's built for iteration
it has this you you have the ability to
rename give a different name for the
concept that you're iterating on merge
split or remove these sets of kind of
this multi-classifier system that is in
this case what you're seeing sorry I
realized I skipped over kind of exactly
what the model was you can see here this
is a basically a linear
uh combination or a
the classifier output
is a linear model over these uh kind of
high enough f-score uh regular
expressions
um over that that grammar that I
described and
um and you can see over the left hand
side uh for each piece you know document
or piece of data that you would label
um the predicted if there's a prediction
the label and also an expl like what
part match one of the patterns
um so um you could also promote a
pattern that was not selected to be used
as part of this linear imagine we've
basically figured that again this
balance between accuracy and
transparency you know up to five regular
expression rules with a linear uh uh
combination of we felt like that was as
complex as we were willing to go to get
accuracy but not lose kind of the
ability for the human to kind of Reason
um and have an accurate mental model of
what the model is doing on the data oh
yes I have a question so for the
predicted price is that so are you
essentially adding the labels of what
you think should be a valid codes for
this and they're finding them or are
they looking at the data seeing
similarities and suggesting a code right
okay it's like if this is a mixed
initiative system who's taking the first
initiative or like how much information
because it gives your take the computer
does not suggest codes
um it is uh the conversation because
again you're thinking of that that Loop
the the human still has their own
internal research question that the
computer doesn't know anything about
they will start they will give a couple
examples and that's what kicks off the
response and then back and forth
there's a follow up on that actually in
that Loop
if I just select 10 coupon is that
enough for it to generalize or like how
how many examples do I need to give for
this thing to kick off roughly ah gosh
that's a really great question
um I think it's uh I don't know if we
start generating patterns for a single
example it may be you know two or three
but I'll have to check with with simrit
but it's a small number it's a very
small quite right this is few shot
learning right um not zero shot but few
shot
um and so
um
what's uh what's
um really nice actually and it's not
shown in the screenshot but it's shown
in a in like two slides um is that once
you have these kind of patterns
um over the data you can uh reorder
these based on kind of um the kind of
certainty or you know like the uh you
could you could group them by uh which
pattern of the patterns in the model
they satisfy so you could look at you
know there's various ways you can
leverage those patterns to kind show
people uh groups and then also if
something is marked wrong
right you can look at why it sparked
wrong and you can you can annotate on
the piece of code not only like is this
wrong and here's the right label but
here's the part of it that you should be
looking at where where you know one
where a human would look uh that maybe a
future pattern should satisfy
um and you could also see when it's
right for the wrong reason and then say
yeah it is about price but not because
you highlighted the date because of this
this word over here instead
and and that will of course trigger a
recomputation of the patterns that best
fit and the linear uh uh model over them
yes
let's say that there was a person who
did not mention price and it was not
about price at all is that going to
cause a problem are they expecting that
pattern to show up in every single one
of the participants or no right so so
this um see that theme drop down
that the person thematic analysis you're
often going to come up with multiple you
know yes so so you can you can choose to
work on you could create a new theme you
could switch between thieves you're
working on yeah
I think add labels for other thieves but
your your um uh you're looking at all
the data okay it's just does it exist in
there or not it's just is it yeah like
okay price or not and and you could kind
of group them in different ways
yeah yeah it's
actually quite
um
yeah it's uh it uh it's it's a tough
system I think um all the details will
not be able to come out in this talk but
I I hope that you'll look at the the
camera ready too
um
uh so yeah so this is uh the user can
understand and validate or modify the
model directly right um they can uh like
remove or promote various regular
Expressions to be included kind of
forcefully they could also uh indirectly
correct just uh by annotating additional
examples or correcting what parts of
those examples are the part that the
you're telling the computer to focus on
so um you know if you're if you're
looking at kind of the entire
architecture you have uh the user starts
annotating data um over there at one
Pat learns the pattern of users
annotations and synthesizes rules based
over um the grammar um it selects a set
of rules that can capture the broadest
you know kind of uh some notion of
coverage and quality um not you know
labeling things that the person is
already explicitly reliable to something
else
um and uh and then the user can kind of
group and rank the data on the left hand
side
um based on these different possible
grouping modes and ranking methods like
show me the things that it's most
confident about or show me the things
it's least confident about and
um
uh and then also you know um these
modifications uh as you kind of iterate
on the code book so
um you can see here
sorry I like
um it's very small
um but uh you can see
um
a little bit of this is an example of
how you can look at things grouped by
similarity from a kind of a Bert
standpoint
um
you have
let's see you have a pattern filter so
you can look at all the sentences that
matched a particular regex within the
model either one that's within the model
already or one that's kind of uh in the
wings waiting to be promoted potentially
so you can it's highlighting the piece
uh that is uh that was the reason that
it matched the pattern in every one of
those examples in in blue so that can
make it you know we're just like looking
at like are there different ways to even
just help people speed up consuming the
recommendations
um and so
um they can also as you can see here
right um they can see when they look at
that blue Highlight the pattern that it
matched and what that pattern was
um they can tell uh
system that that wasn't the right
pattern they can split so price might
actually be two subtly different
categories like price and money and then
um
uh author kind of two models out of the
original one and this is my favorite
because this is the part that makes it
neurosymbolic but is still intelligible
or legible because I I really hate when
the system is just like and then it
magically does something and I'll never
know why like this is showing all the
things in the data
that were considered with respect to the
large language bottle similar enough
right these are kind of the synonyms
right so I know I can go through and for
each one of these if I want right for
that soft match I could say oh that is a
misunderstanding of that word
right or in this context that's not a
synonym even though on average it
usually is and I can explicitly Say
Never match those two in this context
and so there's just really a level of
control
and legibility that that I I look for in
every one of my systems that has a neuro
part of the symbolic
yes yeah I have a question about looking
at the patterns I guess from like um
someone who's like doing coding so I
look at this model that sees all these
weights how am I supposed to interpret
that like am I supposed to say this
regular expression is more important
than another or is it supposed to just
help me that's a great question
um I I mean
I think strictly speaking
saying that you know and when you have a
so like point nine that the weight on um
numb or ex or soft match on expensive
for this notion of price like you could
you know say like and also it's not
clear to me that these weights are
actually like normalized
um so
um I I
um did not read you know like in terms
of discussions with the lead student and
our write-up there was very little
discussion of kind of this notion of
um priority like focusing more on One
Thing versus another it is it's a it's a
it's a think of it as like soft
information right
um and um
and but you can click on that filter say
for prop n or ordinal right with a minus
0.02 like it's like it almost like never
factors in and like very little bit and
kind of like you could click on that and
say what is matching here right like and
and then um you can kind of debug from
there
maybe it's it's right to have it it's
not it's it's again this is like
so basic but we're trying to be
expressive enough to be accurate enough
to be useful while still maintaining
legibility and it's just this balancing
act I don't think there's any like true
right answer
okay so let's take a look at the
evaluation uh we had eight experienced
qualitative coders come in they each
spent two hours with us they experienced
three different conditions on one of two
data sets uh and then we talk to them
afterwards about their experience they
um in each condition they had 100 unique
data points from the same data set so
they were working on the same data set
throughout the two hours but they were
seeing different data in each condition
it was either restaurant reviews or hate
speech so
um I think the hate speech Choice like I
we flagged that in the informed because
then it was like
um uh uh and I think it was it was
filtered such that it was not
um uncomfortable for our study uh hoax
but it is I think important in terms of
its um ambiguity
you know I I think actually there's
someone in the room who's done really
great work with deang one of your new
professors on the the you know on on um
the contextual nature of that if I
remember your work correctly
um so I think it's it's an important
task
um representative task um so we would
give them a research question
to uh to the qualitative coding and um
and counterbalance order they
experienced a baseline version of batat
without any AI
uh Bert
um so it's a version of batat that only
had the Black Box model so there's no
explanation highlights on items or
display of learned patterns now I guess
you could have added some sort of like
post-hoc analysis you know I think um
but uh that that is the choice that we
made here
um and then um uh so also a lot of the
strategies that relied on patterns were
no longer available as well though you
could do
um you know kind of like uh kind of
burnt level semantic grouping
um and then of course with the full
features that I told you so
um we asked people to rank from first to
Third and then kind of showed
um
for the manual condition it was almost
uh always first place for ease of use
and perceived user control uh too
surprising
um Bert didn't really win any
competition
uh and then patat
um was uh most frequently ranked first
place for usefulness at facilitating
human learning of data so given that
that last one was like the design goal
number one like we can all go home now
um but I I uh we won't because I'll I'll
tell you a couple other uh qualitative
insights um so in in looking over
people's comments on their experiences
um
they felt that understanding um we we
observed that understanding the current
state of the model did contribute to
error Discovery and repair
uh so this is maybe less about kind of
persons intent changing but rather
recognizing that the computer's
interpretation of their intent isn't
correct
um so participants found user
interpretable patterns synthesized um
for them to be valuable
um so you know if it is coding for good
price I'm looking for a positive
adjective plus a synonym for Price or
discounts or whatever when I see that
it's on the right track of doing
something like that it makes me more
confident this ability to predict maybe
on data they haven't looked at yet
um and uh its ability to capture things
that I may have missed if I were the
only one going through the data
um so so yeah so so this uh these are
these patterns are interpretable enough
that our our qualitative coders can
leverage them in the way that we wanted
um
now there are some codes so ideas like
atmosphere or discrimination that
um are more challenging to capture with
the grammar over which we are
synthesizing patterns and so for this
you know you kind of have just naturally
lower accuracy
um of the system and so in this case
people
um kind of more just instead of looking
at the
patterns as the system is trying to find
five regular Expressions over our
grammar that would capture
atmosphere
um instead people looked at the data
right so going through the highlighted
words was kind of the way that they
dealt with uh that kind of shortcoming
of what what I think any system
ultimately would struggle with
um
differential patterns also facilitate
the discovery of new themes Trends and
connections right and this goes back to
kind of that human over on the left hand
side of our Loop right where um yes they
have an initial intent or initial idea
expectation but um in a real system
especially in thematic analysis but in
many other situations too uh
acknowledging and facilitating the
evolution of what they want is really
really critical so
um the patterns also captured outliers
that help people notice uh important
details and nuanced aspects of the data
that help them further refine what they
wanted
um so um
so one person said I'm seeing ideas
around women coming up with ideas around
violence more they had patterns of
different words like language around
body parts near uh language about women
so if I'm interested in gender and
sexuality if I'm seeing actually more
specific language about body parts that
we're talking about this is like this
could be useful this could be a
direction to further interrogate the
data to pull that for a little bit does
this mean that depending on the support
you gave me it shifted the kinds of
themes I was identifying
okay sorry you are jumping to the next
slide can I go to say uh I'm a player
there's there's this really really
tricky question that when you
go past what the normal controlled user
study is where it's like hey your intent
is to label price go right
um and instead you're like you are to
you know come up with whatever themes
it's much harder to ask what is the
impact of this assistance on where I get
right and if there is impact that's not
necessarily bad it's not necessarily
good right so like it's always kind of
like impact agnostic and so the best
thing I think this is a really tough
evaluation challenge for us because I
think we should not be giving people
intent we should be letting them choose
their intent so we could better
understand the whole Loop when we're
evaluating our systems but this is our
so what you can see here is uh the
different color bars correspond to the
different conditions and we kind of just
tried to create a linear ordering over
the names of codes
that came up in any condition so that
you could see like okay so here's um in
in potat Bert and manual religion came
up you know and that that was like kind
of like uh but you can see there's
there's some variation how many things
were tag religion you can see in manual
both identified gender asexuality You
could argue is
well if you're a woman's a dead or
studies like uh that's entirely
different but maybe to our qualitative
coders they thought that was the same
thing
um anyway so you can see that there's
some
convergence that there may be are like I
I don't want to say look the system got
you where you were ever you were going
to get if you were just doing it
manually I can't say that but this is
the best picture I could give you at the
moment with the kind of the evaluation
that we have
um to say that you know I mean you can
definitely see things like um service
um showed up immensely at Bert Bert was
like service this is a thing
you should tag it right and people
responded to that by by tagging it and
and that didn't seem to come up as much
as like an idea in the manual in the
patat right and so like I think they're
you're seeing some Divergence in what
people call out
but I can't say if it's good or bad
does that answer your question yeah I
don't
care about good or bad it's just
fascinating to think about
how it shapes my thinking right what
does it guide me toward
the the
it's something that could
shape where you ultimately go yes
um so I'm not sure if this is a great
question but I'm just curious
um so I suppose like when you're using a
technology like this that like helps
with coding like faster more efficiently
um I would wonder kind of like
tell you if but if a patat like helps
also like assessing like say good things
if like the resulting codes that you
might come up with like for instance
like if you're able to now try out a
whole bunch of different codes right you
there's like also this risk that maybe
you find one in particular that's
interesting yeah but you've also tried
like 50 now whereas like before maybe
you only tried like a couple oh I see
what you say basically like it's not so
much amplifying your effort in terms of
like oh and it's got It's it's
pre-digested all these additional things
that you might also code with that same
thing right kind of like a longitudinal
thing you're saying it's kind of
amplifying your exploration of the data
because it supports it makes it easier
to go wide
yeah I'm just I'm just asking maybe I I
hadn't thought about that at all it's a
great question
um you know I mean my gut would say that
yes like you know the same way that like
a traditional interactive machine
learning like with every additional
annotation I give if I change my mind
later I have to like redo my work it's
not really you know facilitating
Evolution
um I think that patat is designed to
facilitate Evolution so I think maybe
people are less inhibited to yeah let me
create a new thing if later it converges
the same thing I I have some patterns
for over there I can I can literally
merge them
yes this is an interesting question but
you were talking about how like this
diverged I did it manually since I used
to attack I'm curious based on from the
AI behind where some of it is more on
some of it it's like parts are so if it
is more transparent some of it isn't if
I did it first it did it would there be
a difference in what codes that we see
because if we annotated differently
right the odds of us having a different
code it just well the odds of you having
the same set of models yes you would you
might come up with different codes and
even if you came up with the same name
with the same kind of underlying
intended meaning you might given you
gave slightly different examples from
the data set have different models that
would predict that code on future data
so I guess one interesting graph to to
kind of remake here or to make a new
would be to break this down by uh
there's unfortunately only eight people
in this study but to see you know how
much variation
it's actually because like one of the I
guess issues when it comes to
experimental methods is like people
decide to analyze data differently and
so as a result how well can you trust
what happened because even as good as
researchers as we are right we have
these biases and we decided to analyze
it in this way so is it really
significant or do we just haven't have a
leaning in this way yeah so I'm curious
if this is I think I think that patat is
the goal with batat is to like
facilitate you being you and because you
being you and Jim being Jim are
different people each with your own
internal kind of values and research
questions or observations that you think
are slightly more interesting like I
think the system is not going to
necessarily there's nothing here that I
think would drive you like would make
you converge that's a that's a problem
with qualitative coding and I shouldn't
even say a problem it's a it's just how
it is and it's it's a beautiful thing uh
it's a little antithetical to how we
often like to operate in The Sciences
but it's an important tool
um and we kind of have to trust the
people who are doing it to be aware of
you know so great question
um uh
though I will caveat on what I said I
said like oh it's probably not going to
drive you to converge I don't know that
about like if it was it was Bert and and
with tat
um
like I said earlier there are certain
ideas that are easier to capture with
the tat
and you know maybe that's something that
would be a place where people kind of
converge on things that were easier to
capture rather than more amorphous like
atmosphere or discrimination
okay so I'll just point out to wrap up
this section and oh my goodness
such great questions so
um I just point out that like uh having
the data that's annotated with the parts
of the pattern that it matched that
matched it
um and having the programs visible both
those things together it's common ground
right the same thing that helps us
effectively communicate one idea to
another human helps us communicate it
with the AI and feel that we know that
it was communicated so having both the
data and the written programs is really
helpful to help refine both the concept
and the user's mind and the tasks that
they want the computer to do for them
it's really great I'm sorry I'm such a
using language fan here um Herbert Clark
is my hero uh common ground is the
foundation of altering actions essential
to the creation of the speakers meeting
and addresses understanding
so um with that I'll come back to our
kind of accumulating uh with details
Loop here
um and
um
uh kind of use this as a segue to say
okay
um you know we
um
uh let's think about that was exciting
because AI was helping us and that's
kind of like all the rage
um let's just really quickly talk about
um systems that I are near and dear to
my heart where there is no automation
I'm just helping you figure out what you
want
um more than maybe you would otherwise
be able to and I'm just going to go
through this uh really quickly this was
just presented at West a system is
called paralib kind of like parallel
libraries or comparison and the title of
the paper is concept annotated examples
for Library comparison
um and so uh basically it's it's uh that
most most programmers
um
have to make Library decisions and when
they are trying to do something there's
many different libraries that have very
similar but slightly distinct operations
can we help you formulate what you want
to do given this landscape uh can we
augment the existing landscape of
information about what's out there that
includes these kind of summarizing lists
these high level stuff
um
you know we looked at the literature in
terms of what people are
um what kind of needs for understanding
um what's out there that maybe these
prior the current websites have
um and like fit for purpose size
complexity usability I think my argument
is that they're easier some of these
things are easier to assess just looking
at the code itself and like oh my God D3
that's going to take me a page of code
and it's going to take me five lines in
Vega like but Vega can't do X right you
know anyway looking at the code I think
for programmers can be really helpful
more helpful than just you know
beautiful visualizations SVG
um so the problem is is that if you are
only looking at a couple examples of
code which is typically all we have uh
generalizing from only a couple examples
could Lead You astray that would be
overfitting in a human sense
um what if you know if we could show
them a bunch of examples maybe they
would be less likely to make incorrect
generalizations but it's really hard to
compare multiple you know many many
examples at once
um so let's a reason why I'm really
excited about telling you about this
paper is because I think there's
exciting design implications of these
theories of human concept learning that
you too could borrow
there's two that I want to tell you
about really quickly the first one is
variation Theory variation Theory says
I'm summarizing here deeply so apologies
to ference Martin but showing sets of
many examples in parallel That Vary
along either critical or superficial
dimension of variation helps humans
identify those Dimensions as a useful
coordinate space to describe the concept
that the examples are drawn from I
realize I just read that slide off to
you I'm doing that because this is these
are not his words this is my best way to
translate what he's saying into the
language that we use as best I can
um uh you know um uh you could think you
know like if an alien came to Earth and
he said what's a computer and I could
say well these are all computers right
I'm showing him a set of parallel
examples that vary in color but color is
a dimension of variation that exists for
computers but does not define you know
is not part of defining the boundary
right but you can do that kind of over
and over again to help people
um come up with a correct
generalizations right it can help
Learners develop more robust accurate
inferences about what dimensions and
values within those dimensions are and
aren't critical to defining the
boundaries of what is uh of a concept
and what's contained within it the
second theory of human concept learning
that is uh relevant
um is analogical learning theory
gentner's work
um and of course all her students and
her collaborators and I mean she
one of The Originators but not the only
person working on it highlighting
analogical Dimensions uh across examples
kind of like you know the head of this
dog and his cat right it could help
people obviously it's obvious to us as
as fellow mammals that those are the
dimensions of that those are aspects of
mammals but for code examples it's not
obvious if you're new
so um
uh basically our hypothesis was that if
we annotated common aspects of many code
examples side by side kind of the
joining of variation Theory and
analogical learning theory in the
context of code examples
um that could facilitate programmers
Library comparison uh at the code level
so basically you know we
um because this is actually a tech probe
as opposed to a fully functioning system
so it's just kind of the you know we we
hallucinate that we have these kind of
um uh uh expert annotated
um Concepts uh sorry I'm I'm using
Concepts and aspects interchangeably now
which is very confusing
um bear with me but um you know creating
a legend
um uh binding data we can highlight
where that happens in the code across
multiple different libraries to help you
see the correspondences and the
distinctions
um so you could call this you know
concept or aspect annotated code
examples
um so that we wanted to help people
inspect those concrete examples compare
functionalities in their Associated
syntax help them assess how easy it is
to use each Library
um anticipate like you know how much
code they'd need to write and all that
kind of and also typicality right like
what is this code typically looking like
um so
um
this is our interface it's really tough
to look at
um I am actually going to deviate from
the plan and say this is a paper I
invite you to read if this is exciting
to you what I really wanted to tell you
about was those those theories of human
concept learning because you know
short answer this helps people make more
consistent decisions that were
appropriate for their task and to help
them recognize like oh you know uh
recharge uses the same syntax as react
and I don't I've I tried react last year
I hated it right but but chase you know
um but uh this other one you know uses
it builds on it's a library within some
Library that's that's more familiar to
me or I'm more comfortable with
um anyway so so
um but these theories of human concept
learning are incredibly powerful right
we want to work with human cognition so
I recommend those if you are you want to
start in a good place a good initial
place
you know in terms of how you show help
people make sense of lots of data going
back to how Michael introduced me in the
beginning because I'm still trying to do
that to this day
um the final point I want to make
is just a very quick
um kind of this is a um yes it's the
best paper yay at IUI 2020 in March in
Italy
it did not happen
um but
um the the title really says it all and
by the way this is work uh led by Zana
vachynka and Phoebe Lin who were
Kristoff's and my students respectively
that the summer before they did
incredible work
um uh and
um you know what they found
um uh in a they they had a uh I I tell
this to you as a warning
um
you know they looked at it at a very toy
example I'll just tell you this up real
quick so you understand it they um kind
of had a um they looked at a proxy task
this was Mechanical Turk but uh you know
a proxy task of like examples to explain
um what uh the AI might be looking at
when deciding how much fat content is in
it and so the proxy task is trying to
predict what the AI would do based on
either examples or some sort of kind of
deductive description of the contents
right so this is a not um the actual
task would be deciding for yourself with
the ai's assistance right so this is the
non-proxy task with the same kind of
inductive and deductive possible
explanations where you're deciding not
you're not simulating the AI you're
deciding for yourself with an ai's
recommendation
what we found is that
um when you had give people not the
actual tasks that they would do in the
real world to test the value of
inductive versus deductive explanations
you found that people prefer the
inductive explanation and didn't prefer
the deductive
but when you had them actually you know
do the AI assisted task where they're
making a decision suddenly their
preferences switch but the thing they
didn't prefer is where they did better
um and so you know if we had relied
again if we as the title applies if we'd
relied on the proxy task we might have
gotten kind of misleading signals about
where to invest our time
um now you can get a table like that in
pretty much any study and set you know
um so the reason why I feel comfortable
kind of like saying like hey this might
this is this is really important to
share with you is because I'm seeing
this again in our more recent work on
co-pilot right so co-pilot um uh use
large language models to uh you know
predict the next
code that you might write um when we had
a
you know kind of like a
uh sorry let's see um
when we had I gave them a fake task and
we compared kind of like a standard kind
of just deterministic recommender versus
the AI generated code
um they over relied on the AI they
rabbit hold some of them finished really
quickly and those that didn't finish
really quickly ran out of time and never
finished because they were debugging
code that had been you know was rehashed
to other people's code that they didn't
understand okay but when we actually had
them bring in their own projects into
conceptual inquiry they no longer did
this problematic over Reliance they had
appropriate Reliance they validated
everything that the AI recommended and
they wanted explanation so the design
recommendations for what to do to
support people and receiving AI
recommended code is very different
between the kind of like we fix the
intent
and we get that external validity so is
this just
um you know my final thought uh uh
encouragement to you as fellow
researchers
is
um
if we keep getting these kind of like
reversals when we look at a controlled
study in the lab and our contextual
inquiry
I feel very uncomfortable
uh I think what that that given that you
know we've talked about so many times
now that this is a loop that every time
we evaluate a system where we don't
allow people to Loop through and change
their intent
right that we that we fix the intent we
say this is a controlled study you are
trying to implement dynamic programming
go right you know like that that we we
may be potentially misleading ourselves
in the evaluation and and in the where
we put our time
in developing uh um uh better better
tools so
um I will I will end there and um
welcome any additional questions
thank you
[Applause]
yeah it was time for a couple questions
nice quick do you plan to put the beta
open GitHub or something I'm sorry the
beta the first one is open yeah I'm
sorry you're planning to put it on live
available or GitHub or something uh that
would be lovely
um simra is kind of the she's a lead
graduate student and I think she
um uh I will encourage her to to do that
um I but well we actually Toby and I and
another collaborator are hoping to
um uh request more money from the NSF uh
and and maybe Implement um some of those
ideas into already existing open
Frameworks that have been funded in part
by IBM
um for this kind of qualitative coding
so so I hope that the features if not
the system itself the features will
become publicly available through other
means
hi thank you
um for your late breaking work do you
have like a hunch as to why you saw that
switch is because people didn't like
where people
behaving
differently yes like like a bit like
like why I guess like yeah is that it
Stakes
so um I'm doing some follow-up work uh
with one of my newer graduate students
um where it's like okay
um you know if if if you're programming
on something that I gave to you that
you're gonna walk away from and never be
troubled by again you know you will be I
want to say lazy yeah you're going to
conserve your mental energy okay to say
it a little nicer
um uh but when it's something that
really affects you right or maybe um you
know I'm interacting with um a a a
generative model and I'm I'm you know is
that art gonna go up on my wall
or am I going to walk away at the end of
the study and be like well that was fun
I got 15 bucks you know um I think that
like if we I think we need to kind of I
don't want to say raise the stakes in an
uncomfortable way but like find Stakes
that are meaningful
um because I think that that's gonna
help us recognize that people are being
appropriate Reliant when the stakes are
meaningful and not kind of get like um
kind of over concerned about
over-reliance we see in situations that
are actually quite unrealistic
um so I'm curious like if you could
expand on like maybe design choices you
might think could help with Stakes so
like I'm thinking of like money right
but like that's not really a practical
solution but you're kind of thinking
about like uh bringing in actual
projects like maybe or like do you have
other ones maybe fashion contextual
inquiry I think is the place to start
um there's one other thing that I'm
experimenting with right now which is to
um you know we care we we are members of
society we care about what other people
think of us and I think that we can
leverage
relationships in a non-threatening way
right so I'll give you an example
um like
uh this is very outside of what I
normally do but you know
um having someone we say like hey if you
like this your goal is to come up with
something funny to share with a friend
right who are you hoping to share this
with okay you know prom you know in the
next 15 minutes if you get to something
you say you're happy enough with you
open up your email and you email it to
them
if you're not willing to email it to
it's not good enough yet keep going
until you know if we run out of time we
run out of time you don't there's no
compuls we're not compelling them to
share something with a friend but we by
by having them do that in you know it
makes it real it's like well my friend's
gonna ask you why'd you send me that
that thing what was that about you're
like oh I was in the state but it's
still you make it so I mean I obviously
I don't want to make people
uncomfortable so it's a very delicate
delicate balance
all right I think we are about at time
so Elena will hang out here for a moment
after the talk if you have additional
questions let's thank our speaker
[Applause]
[Music]